food trucks are among those small
businesses that have certainly struggled
during the pandemic
and the only authentic japanese food
truck in our state is based right here
in las vegas
we've got rocky theaters out there live
at the matsuri food truck with
their journey hey oh look at you you're
right inside there rocky
yes hey kirsten yeah what do you want
what was your order
yakisoba okay coming right up i got you
come on in
to my surrey food truck i'm here with
owners brittany and joseph
so we're going to make a really special
dish what's it called yucky sober right
yeah
let's talk about how this dish is made
and what you guys do all right
so very first thing we're going to hit
hit the grill with some oil i like to go
ahead and do that with some oil
there you go japanese street food
festival food
so explain that to people explain your
concept yes so it's kind of like an
overlooked
uh aspect of japanese cuisine um so it's
a lot of the
you know fried noodles fried octopus all
that good stuff
um you know comfort food beer food good
yeah i love it and it's also 98 degrees
in here
so hard for this community and obviously
like kristen said earlier this is the
only food truck of this time
in las vegas yep but you guys have had
to go through some things during the
pandemic obviously so let's talk about
your journey
and just you know how hard it's been for
you all yeah so um
initially when povid first happened um
you know we got hit with a lot of
xenophobia unfortunately
um anybody who doesn't understand what
that means is a really strong
hate or dislike people have a different
country right
right um and so you know since
the coronavirus had the tie to the asian
community and then we being the only
yeah good
um the only you know really asian-based
food trucks
right uh we got hit pretty hard uh we
were having people come up and telling
us to go back where we came from
um you know just hateful things throwing
masks at the windows trying to get you
know
um so we had our tip jar stolen at some
point too
um and so basically uh we made the
decision to shut down
um because you know we weren't sure what
was gonna happen i run the truck by
myself at night usually
um and so just for safety reasons we
shut down
um we actually reopened again recently
uh and it just kind of you know it's
slow still
but it's getting there it's slow but
it's getting there and that's the kind
of progress we like to hear yeah
obviously now we can eat
and how can people enjoy you guys yeah
so um
we are we travel around here you can
find yeah
uh social media instagram facebook uh
twitter we are under matsuri lv
and then uh live streaming on twitch as
well okay oh and coming up later in the
show we're going to explain
what that live streaming on twitch means
because that's that's something that
it's really helped you guys
build back up yeah definitely it's been
a life saver it's some good advice for
small businesses coming up later in the
show i'll send it back to you guys
don't be jealous that looks so good